[Music]
more stuff coming at you this time we've
got some interesting things pertaining
to bomb arrows so if you enjoy this
series give this video a like we're just
glad that you guys enjoy breath of the
wild as much as we do alright here we go
did you know that bomb arrows shot in
the rain can still explode you're used
to having your bomb arrows become weak
duds when shot in the rain but
technically they're still alive just
have the unignited arrow in a covered
spot or just wait till the rain stops
then take any fire source to the bomb
arrow on the ground and it will set it
off even a piece of flint works
and to top it off shooting a bomb arrow
with another bomb arrow launches them
and ignites them making a secondary
explosion
stun knocks can be tough to break apart
the only consistent way to do this is to
fire a bomb arrow at its eyeball
[Music]
but there is one secret weapon out there
that can break them apart at any time
the almighty bookshelf
just swing this hunk of metal at them
and they'll fall apart instantly making
their eyeball easy pickings not even the
mighty large iron box can do this trick
did you know that mipha's first concept
wasn't the typical shark fin zora design
she was originally modeled after the
venomous lionfish with fins that would
fan out and expand when she's engaged in
combat while i personally thought that
this was an insanely cool design going
with the more gentle and cute appearance
does fit her personality a little bit
better perhaps we could spend some time
together
did you know the center of buoyancy for
every pot is slightly different goron
pots turn straight up and down normal
and rideau pots tilt sideways and zoro
pots flip completely upside down nothing
really useful about this at all but the
fact that the developers even put time
into thinking about this is pretty
interesting over the years many players
have tried to ride a horse in the desert
while people can get the horse there
riding it freely around the desert sands
is pretty much impossible but wild
animals such as bears and deer don't
count in this category
using horse wrong warping you can now
explore the desert sands with your dear
friend
when it comes to shrines with targus
there's no need to use this annoying
cannon bomb contraption just use a bomb
arrow on the targets and at this shrine
specifically multi-shot bomb arrow will
take out both of these targets at the
same time
[Music]
an old thing many players still don't
know about is that science can be read
and examined even after being cut off
its post it even depends which side it
fell on as you can't read a sign that's
face down which makes sense
moblins are known for tossing their
friends at you dealing damage equal to
the throne enemies based melee damage
what's interesting though is that for
stall enemies the body and the head
damage is calculated differently with
the body itself doing one heart of
damage but any skull doing two and a
half hearts of damage and a knock down
instead
if you want a really dumb but
entertaining way to get height head to
death mountain and get at least a couple
hundred bomb arrows do a bow smuggle
then switch to your bomb arrows you'll
start to constantly explode over and
over while actually gaining height funny
thing is after the first bomb you don't
take any further damage because of
ragdoll protection and even protects you
against death mountain's hot air which
will stop burning you after a while you
have gotten pretty high up
someone mentioned in the last video
about having the final memory cut scene
being slightly different if you take a
picture of a photo on the wall first the
cool thing that people didn't notice is
that this wall has a special filter that
won't detect and capture your equipment
accidentally in third person
and instead sees that you've taken a
picture of the photo link will now
instead recall the photo that you've
taken instead of simply looking around
and flashing back without any references
ah just like i remember it
wait a minute
[Music]
there's an old trick of throwing a
boomerang that allows you to have a
circle around you called boomerang
orbiting but have you tried it with the
luzofos arm instead the designs it makes
can be quite mesmerizing
divali's gail is now ready quiet ravali
guardians have a strange weak spot on
the top of their head if you fire a bomb
arrow at its head while it's moving
around it'll often flip right over this
is less likely to work on the guardian
of stationary as all six legs anchor it
in place
did you know that rainbows can occur at
night
i don't know how this is physically
possible but okay if you take a closer
look at king rome's secret study in
hyrule castle there's an old tattered
portrait on the wall with a really
intricate frame above his desk what's
interesting though is that the
developers plan to put a portrait of the
royal family here with king rome zelda
and zelda's mother the queen but by the
looks of it this idea was scrapped never
to be seen i guess our only look at
zelda's mother we have so far is in this
one cut scene in age of calamity on
nintendo's official hiring website there
are some hidden unlisted videos you may
not have seen before one of them
showcases the importance of graphical
effect design and how to telegraph
information to the players a side by
side shows that it's impossible to
understand what to do without seeing the
effects themselves such as showing when
updrafts are active when an enemy attack
will strike and punchy sword effects
while striking enemies this shows just
how important it is to have good effects
in game development
there's a secret combat technique in
breath of the wild called a shielded
flip while i won't go into all of its
applications because there are a ton of
complex and intricate ways to use this
my personal favorite one hands down is
its ability to thunderclap rush after
you mount a lynel's back which looks
pretty awesome
it's a little too much to explain what's
going on from scratch if you don't know
multiple advanced techniques beforehand
but if you'd like us to go in depth with
cool techniques like this let us know
you can also take a peek at my combat
glossary
[Music]
did you know that yiga foot soldiers use
quote unquote real ninjutsu before
teleporting to attack you they summon
cursed hylian letters in a seal before
they attack in clockwise order they read
out as din pyo to
kai
completing the kuji incantation and a
side note you may not have known you can
flurry rush this attack
[Applause]
someone recently pointed out that you
can make a full-on train using minecarts
at death mountain by using certain
weapons or treasure chests to push the
caboose cart as an engine you can create
your own little spirit train the coolest
part hands down with this whole ordeal
is that breath of the wild's audio
design was so top notch that this whole
thing naturally sounds like an actual
working train without the developers
directly intending to listen for
yourself
[Music]
it's very clear that wind cleavers had
the yiga in mind for its use as the
blade masters easily strike you from a
distance with its wind slash attack but
other enemies have some problems using
this weapon as the slash moblins make
can simply be crouched under because the
moblin is too tall and the bokoblins are
so short that it can simply be shield
jumped over
these ancient furnaces carry the blue
flame that powers ancient technology and
obviously can be transferred via arrow
or burnable weapons
but did you know that there's another
strange way to carry them multi-shot
fire arrows carry the fire just as well
and on top of that even bomb arrows
carry the blue flame well at least for a
short distance until they explode from
the ancient fire's heat man this makes
me want an ancient bomb arrow now
and there you go what was your favorite
thing you learned this time let us know
in the comments below and if you
continue to enjoy new breath of the wild
videos we have a playlist of tons of
stuff we still make to this day for
everything else gaming keep it here on
gamespot
[Music]
you